[Music]
what started out as a two-cent magazine
to sell knickknacks in 1930 is now a
global comic phenomenon worth over seven
billion dollars when two chains heard
Dinesh shamdasani had some early
editions of his favorite characters he
couldn't resist jumping into the action
all right what's going on they tell me
you are the man with the magazines not
just magazine Comics I'm a I'm a
man-child a grown man that is obsessed
with childish things when I was coming
up you know
not too long ago I
two enjoy looking at certain Comics tell
me a little bit about where your passion
came from to collect they teach you
about life I'm gonna sound so silly here
but they do they teach you about life
they teach you lessons you see
allegories for the for the world for how
you should behave as you grow up and you
learn different things and you get to
different stages of life you see
different things in the characters
they've existed for so long so many
great writers and artists have been
involved they imprint their souls onto
the books and the stories I mean it's
just it's amazing is it a huge market
for Comic and collecting Comics I mean a
comic book market for reading is is I
mean Global the movie's obviously helped
the video games the toys Etc and
collecting is becoming more and more and
more of a huge component of it got it
now I see you have a Ninja Turtles yes
construction made comic now yeah I know
about the Ninja Turtles fan you don't
know about you know what this is teenage
digital is number one it's the first
comic book the way you make comics is
you you look at a proof a very early
draft printed and you check all the
spelling that says you check it looks
right to come this existed this is the
printer's proof they approve that's why
the cover looks janky like that they
draw the art they send it to the printer
the printer sends them this and says
does it look the way you thought it
would look and they say yes or they say
no no the black's aren't printing right
the you miss the page printing wrong so
they prove that and then would they Mass
produce it so this is a printer's proof
princess proof of the first special
yeah it feels special and it looks
special the outside you really can't
tell it's my favorite part put on the
inside it has so many details and yeah
and drawings and artwork how much would
something like this cost somebody if
they wanted to buy it from you I've been
offered about 300 to 350 000 I can't
remember exactly it was in that range
y'all going crazy over paper
what year is this
1986 80 something like that damn all
right what else you got up here man this
is my favorite comic of all time Amazing
Fantasy 15. that's Spider-Man obviously
this is the first appearance of
Spider-Man you're gonna see a lot of
these books the characters first appear
in a book that isn't their own book this
book is about three hundred thousand
dollars 350 000 I mean it's just called
one of the greatest covers of all time
most people don't know this Jack Kirby
Drew this cover he drew almost every
major Marvel character's appearance
including this one here Captain America
number one let me see Joe Simonson Joe
Simon and he drew this artwork he's he
along with Jack crib with Jack Urban Joe
Simon drew that book punching Hitler
Captain America is punching Hitler in
the face this is before America entered
the war as well this is their protest
for we should be doing something as Jews
we should be they were thinking we
should the whole country should be doing
something get involved in the World War
II yeah all the way down to the comic
books people were 1948 no how much I
mean just one this is about four hundred
thousand dollars
now what about Spider-Man my son used to
love Spider-Man I know he's turning
seven years old he's shying away from
Spider-Man what would this cover the the
first Spider-Man so you say he was
introduced on his own so Stanley was
running Marvel and it wasn't doing well
because they weren't superheroes yet
they were about to go to business and
his wife said to him just tell one story
the way you want forget what they you
think they want and he wrote this story
Amazing Fantasy 15 first prince of
Spider-Man with a morale a morality tale
and it blew up and then immediately
after this Spider-Man number one comes
out and Fantastic Four X-Men changes the
world this is an invisible comic book
The Staple's Not Invisible they couldn't
figure out the technology what I love
about this this is like Warhol so many
people will say well yes this is the
first prince final you can't read it you
can't open it and read it yes this one
is for sure you can only see the front
and back and many people will buy just
the grade just the look of the cover it
doesn't matter what it looks like this
is like Warhol saying okay we'll just
buy the slab then don't worry about the
rest of it but of course fans are
crazy this thing should be worthless
this is five ten thousand dollars just
this it's just collectors are able to
show off to each other do you have the
invisible comic book it's just a joke
this is a book called Motion Picture
funnies weekly number one there's five
copies in the world this is a book
that's so rare most collectors don't
believe it exists it took me forever to
convince someone to sell me this copy
when I got it most of my friends were
like you've got to send me a photo of
you holding it because I've never seen a
photo in human hands I've been so
tempted to open this because we're not
entirely sure what's inside what we do
know is that this book Marvel Comics
number one which is often considered the
first Marvel book back when they were
called timely Comics that book named the
company it's the first appearance of the
human tortion or the guy that gets so
far from from Fantastic Four and for a
long time will start to be the first
place to name more of the Submariner
then they find this book in an estate
sale for the editor Lloyd jaquette who
also edited the first DC Comic and this
book here the first Marvel comic and
they open it up and they go wait a
minute it predates Marvel Comics and one
and it's got the same story they
reprinted the story so it changes
history these both have the same story
same story with a couple extra pages
there because this book was given away
at movie theaters so they would say come
to the movies we got air conditioning we
got cheap movies and we're gonna give
your kid a little comic to read but of
course everyone throws it away that's
why there's only five in the world
there's very few pictures of the inside
the whole book is not available to look
at it digitally no one really knows
exactly what's in there I want to know
what's inside this thing so bad
so this is probably the most expensive
color book I brought today this is like
Amazing Fantasy 15. this is not Batman's
own title but it's the first appearance
of Batman Detective Comics 27 from 1939.
that's crazy this is first appearance of
Batman and that is an easy million
dollar amazing really bro easy million
64 pages of action yeah what's that
point Paige
this is May
1939 first appearance of Batman Bruce
Wayne now Superman had come out right
before that so you're looking at this
this is worth one million dollars bro
it's worth a little over a million yeah
there's only 35 40 copies that have ever
been graded the collectors that have
them they don't want to let them go
they're never going to find another copy
do they know well I'm sure after seeing
the show that if you do have one you
should let it go it's worth a million
dollars like imagine you not having a
million dollars not living up to some of
the standards and you have this in your
attic redefine spring cleaning I enjoy
Batman because his car the little
dungeon he was in when he used to punch
people to look yeah stuff like that so
I'm with you million dollars the best on
this table how how much do you think we
have on this table all together roughly
how much did you bring out the house
you're gonna embarrass me this is
probably five or six million dollars on
the table here
[Music]
damn what what kind of car you got
I have a minivan oh okay you have a lot
of kids I got three kids shout out I
have three kids shout out to the kids
six million dollars on my table if you
brought five six million in the
collection crazy The Collection all the
comics and a huge comic book art
collector as well so if you look at all
that 15 15 million damn what what is
wrong here's the thing here's why I feel
okay about that I made my money in
comics I lived the American dream I ran
my favorite company of all time the
characters I loved I built it up I made
it amazing we got a movie made then they
fired me that's the American dream and
gave me a lot of money I had it was
called Valiant Comics I have a valiant
shaped hole in my heart and I try to
fill it with all the stuff I loved as a
kid that's that's one of the best
stories I heard on the show thanks man
but now you're up here with me yeah so
you're a winner yeah
foreign